this is gonna be this I'm calling cate
blanchett hello happy Halloween
because it's Halloween and you play you
play the character hella in a movie I'm
sorry who is this
it's Chris the doctor okay um yeah sorry
you've got the wrong number
creepy she definitely knows who I am in
five days
Thor meets Marvel's most evil and
destructive villain yet
real before your queen and that's just
the first 15 minutes
I get ready for Ragnarok is in theaters
in four days not sided have you just set
forward for classic old George my name
is Tessa Thompson and I play Valkyrie
incredible warrior slash bounty hunter
who comes across some interesting
characters what have you brought today
children a contender what we used to
have a big hammer
not so much anymore but he's still just
as soft as he's always been
next up Loki he is a trickster has some
really great moves is a mercurial
mistress of doom and she's someone that
you don't want to mess with I'm the
goddess of death
what were you the god of again wow I
didn't hear any thunder but out of your
fingers is that like sparkles
Grandmaster is kind of a weird
Master of Ceremonies what's not there
Hulk is a big green guy who runs around
the planet and of course likes to smash
things you know I had a fight recently
did I win no I won you know you can
check out for about the rock and cinema
soon
you